was and they were sat in the room.
Anyway, all all the co Benjamin, all the
um people on the right in British
activism were there and we were talking
about ideas. Tommy said something about
someone in the room said something about
we got to reunite with with
Judeo-Christian values. I like can let
me just stop you right there.
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's what
Allah says.
You are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count, brothers and sisters.
and donate towards this message,
inshallah, a new project that's only
$500,000. And believe me, if every
single one of us give £1, £10, £100,
£1,000, that's going to be something you
will never regret on your makama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go, but your deeds and your
makama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video. The
plot thickens, brothers and sisters, as
you look at the 16th of May, march
that's happening in central London where
most likely I'm going to be there on my
D table on Saturday to talk to genuine
British people have genuine concerns who
do not all of them hate Islam and
Muslims etc. And they know very right
this very well that this is funded by
Zionists. The very same Zionist that
funded the Epstein islands. The very
same Zionist I'm going to play a video
of a a a might be a rabbi or a Jewish
Zionist who is insulting Jesus. Yes.
Jesus that you believe in and he's
calling him a whatever word.
>> That's fine.
>> You say that Jesus calling you.
>> That's not offense.
>> Why not? Where? Why should we say that?
>> Why should we say? Why not? What's the
difference?
>> Because the Muslims don't say that.
>> Muslim say he's a Jew.
>> You don't say balls and
>> You say every Jew's going to go to
That's not offensive. That's fine. But
we rejected Jesus.
>> So what? Who was he?
>> HE WAS BASTARD.
>> OH, HERE YOU GO. SO NOW WE'VE GOT THE
ANSWER.
WE KNOW HE'S ABOUT. LOOK,
>> he we know he wasn't the son of God and
you know he wasn't the son of Joseph. So
who the was his father? He was the
son of God.
>> You can fold your arms.
>> You can fold your arms defense.
>> No, he wasn't.
>> You know who you're
son of God.
>> We're getting we're getting to the
>> this scumbag. Okay. He's a scumbag. Why?
Because we love Jesus as much as you
guys do. And you are going to be there
holding Israeli flags. If you are,
you're going to be questioned. You are
going to be asked a question because we
have a right to ask questions. We want
to ask questions that how are you
supporting a group of people? Yes. A
Zionist who are desecrating Jesus Jesus
statues. Yes. Mary's statues bombing
churches that have been there in Gaza
for centuries. Okay. So here is how it
figures because it seems that Kama is
against No, they are working very
closely. Why? Because Kama's wife is a
Zionist. Yes, she's a Zionist. But
before we do that, this is an
interesting thing on X that I'm going to
play with you where to I think his name
is Tony Robinson and another guy who's
Tommy's friends who've worked with him
who are saying, "Hold on a second.
There's something deep in here. This is
not about Britain first. This is not
about the nationalism. This is not about
patriotism. Okay, this is nothing about
that. This is the Israeli Zionists who
are funding this for their judo
Christian values, which is an absolute
oxymoron.
>> May in London.
>> No, I'm not. Um I I don't really like
what these becoming. Go on.
>> Well, they almost I think they serve a
purpose to a degree. If you're new to
all this, it's really good to connect
with people who who that you know, a lot
of these people, they might be on their
own in their way thinking at work, but
it does just feel like a pressure valve.
Like people can go there for the weekend
and they can think, "Yeah, this yeah,
this brilliant. Yeah, we're going to
take back the country." And then they go
back to work and we're still being
invaded. We're still being taxed to
death. We're still, you know,
everything's getting worse. But but
people have managed to have their rant
and rave on a weekend.
>> I said the same thing on Fox and Father
last week. I said, "Lawrence because
Lawrence is going obviously I think he
helps fund it." But to what end? because
this was nice at the beginning. It was
great and obviously I was involved in
organizing the first couple then I gave
it the name United Kingdom but I'm like
but what's the point now? What are we
getting out of it? What's happening? It
seems to nothing it doesn't know
further. People go they wave the flag
around they have a nice time. In fact,
I'll give you a little story I don't
know if I've shared publicly yet, but uh
in the first few meetings, you've got
me, you've got Lawrence Far, you got
Katy Hopkins, you've got Tommy Robinson,
you've got his backers and and there's
no way I can describe them without
sounding like an anti-semite or
something, but they were the
stereotypical overweight Jewish fellows
and they were sat in the room and all of
us and were there and Peter was there
from um hot folks. Um anyway, all all
the car Benjamin, all the um people on
the right in British activism were there
and we were talking about ideas and
Lawrence came up with the hot flag that
we could have as pins. I came up with
the idea uniting the kingdom because
that's what we need to do. We need to
unite Britain again. It's not about
being divisive. It's not about and it's
about being Britain again. And Tommy
said something about or someone in the
room said something about we got to
reunite with with Judeo-Christian
values. I like can let me just stop you
right there. [laughter] I was like this
is great ideas.
>> We had this we had this whiteboard with
all these ideas on it and I think we
posted online at the time. Loads of good
ideas. Um vis 24 was there Stephan and
and I said nothing against any other
peoples or any other demographics but
Great Britain has been a Christian
country since 927 AD. For over a
thousand years we've been an explicitly
Christian country. People can argue that
we have similarities with people of
other faiths if they want. They can
argue that we share similar books if
they want. But Britain has never ever
been described as a Judeo-Christian
country. It's always been described as a
Christian country. I don't agree with
putting anything before Christ. I don't
want it watered down Christianity. And
I'm not saying that people of other
faith are not welcome in Britain.
Although but it is explicitly Christian.
And to give their and I said this in
front of the fat cats quite literally.
And to all of their credit, they all
went, "Oh yeah, you're right." And now
and since because that first rally they
had UK flags, the Union flag, and they
had Israeli flags as well. People
picking up on this. And and I said one
of my bit bits of feedback was we can
have St. George's cross, St. Andrew's
cross. We can have the Union flag. We
can have any British flag. We cannot
have other foreign flags. It's not about
that. It's about us as a people coming
back together. It's about uniting the
kingdom of Great Britain and Northern
Ireland. And to again, to their credit,
all the other rallies since then have
been mostly British flags. So, not not
to look share the story because this is
how close these things come. Well, there
you go. This is people that worked with
him closely and they have
Judeo-Christian values. What are you
talking? That's an oxymoron. You we've
we've shown you the video of the the
Jew. You can't come and tell me that's
just one Zionist believer. No, they
believe this in the doctrine that Jesus
Jesus had no father. They will call him
a B A S T A R D. Yeah, they call his
mother a daughter. Islam came to defend
Jesus and his mother's honor and say no,
that was a miraculous birth. So if
anything, if anything there's
Islam/Christian
values, okay, Judo, it's not
Judeo-Christian, okay? It's Islam
Christian values. Okay, for if that if
there's anything for that matter. So
let's watch and dissect. Here's the
first video where Kama is now blocked or
said that he's going to be blocking
banning people from coming to the march,
those who are instigating, but this is
only going to trigger people to go there
more. So, it's like they are working
together. And who's controlling them?
Yours truly, Zionist. Let's watch it for
yourself here. So, here's the video.
It's happening in the UK and I love
watching it unfold. And if you look
carefully enough, bit by bit, you can
clearly see this operation all coming
together. Well, Karma has just done an
announcement and it's a perfect
advertisement for the upcoming march in
London, May the 16th, United Kingdom.
And this is what he said.
>> And you'll see it again on Saturday at a
march designed to confront and
intimidate this diverse city and this
diverse country. That is why this Labor
government will block farright agitators
from traveling to Britain for that event
because we will not allow people to come
to the UK to threaten our community and
spread hate on our streets.
>> And there's outrage. When have we ever
seen Karma, the government, the
mainstream media ever announce that
there's a rally taking place, especially
when it's Tommy Robinson hosting it?
Never happened. And the Brits are
obviously going to repel against that
because Karma right now is not popular.
We have the local elections and the
narrative is now Karma needs to step
down. He needs to go. And you even got
people in the Labor Parliament that are
all coming together for his resignation.
So, it's going to get the Brits
thinking, "Hang on a minute. Well, I'm
going to go." But at the same time, that
far right word, everyone attaches
theirel too far right because they're
not left. It's the agitators. That's the
key part. Labor not in control. Kiss
armor is not in control. It's an
operation. It's optics. And it's the
agitators that they're banning. Bringing
awareness to these people that are all
part of a network. They all get paid
that are gatekeepers that come over for
self gain. And it's people like Tommy
Robinson that they leech on to because
these people are hiding in plain sight.
They're all part of one massive network
and it's being exposed. And you're
seeing these people all saying the same
thing. Karma lets all these foreigners
in. He lets all these rapists, all these
illegals in. He's not letting in the far
right. So you got K Arma going against
this rally and you got the same people
on the right or supposed to be on the
right that are telling people don't go
Tommy Robinson he's a shield he's a
Zionist they're all saying the same
thing can you not see they're all in one
little bucket now and we're starting to
see it is separating and we're getting
more and more people waking up more and
more people are coming together and more
and more people that are going to see
unite the kingdom you can see I believe
this has been um orchestrated in this
way so to seem like you know Kama Kam
who's look look let's let's just before
we go into that yeah who's Kama's wife
Kama's wife yes Okay. Is um Lady
Victoria Starmmer is Jewish. She's from
po she's from Polish Jewish family and
her faith plays a significant role in
their family life, including observing
the Sabbath and attending the liberal
Jewish synagogue. Now, let's not put
Jews and Zionists in the same category.
She is a Zionist. She's a Zionist. And
for some odd reason, a lot of
influencers, big influencers, they're
all married to Zionist partners.
I mean, it's a coincidence the world
like let's let's be real here, okay? Why
is the Zionists have got their hands
everywhere from Hollywood to the pool
industry to the gambling just they're
just everywhere? Just why? Just why the
politicians Apac Epstein islands h
Muslims behind pulling the strings? Are
we or are we Muslims there fighting you
to stop being degenerate and following
these Zionist Satanists? Yes, the Jews
are free from these Satanists. Okay, for
respect. Okay, so you can clearly see.
So now let's go back to X and let's see.
So as you can see, so there we go. Now
do you see the reaction now? Okay. So
Kar announces he will block all agitated
activists from traveling to UK for Tom
Robert's march the United Kingdom on
Saturday 6. So you see what's happening
on social media below. Now we're going
to go more. We're going to go more.
Okay. Okay. Everywhere you go to
England, you see the St. George flag
union Jack. People just put them up
everywhere. A few people from America
have been banned from speaking at the
March 16 m. It shows they're scared.
Especially when Tommy was in America. I
don't know what that is about. Okay.
Just need to make sure 60 may go
smoothly Tommy because the with the
other marches there's always chance of
trouble. We will get the blame don't get
me wrong etc. So you can see they are
using this to get more propaganda. Now
so I really want to question people on
6th of March in that protest. I just
genuinely I'm I'm not going to go into
the process cuz I don't want to agitate
or you know I I don't want to be seen
like an agitator. I'm an outsider.
People don't like me. They know what I'm
about etc. I I call ST and I have the
civilized dialogues. I'm not here to
cause trouble etc. And we know how the
march went. Last time we went there we
was invited. So if they come to my come
to my table, I really want to ask them
that question. You're carrying an
Israeli Zionist flag and what's that got
to do with Christianity? And I don't
think they have any idea. With all due
respect, Tom Robinson was praised by
Epstein. He was an Epstein file as being
cheap. Yes. Okay. Cheap. Yes. And
something along that matter. So you can
clearly see there is an infight
happening. Why? Because they're waking
up and saying this is not about Britain.
This is not patriotism. This is one man
who's a grifter who's getting paid, who
is being funded by the Zionist for their
own cause. They don't give a damn about
your country, my friend. They don't care
if there's degeneracy. You've got rabbis
that own Pornhub. Yes. Destroying your
girls, your youth to be prostitutes and
well, Taken woke up and said, "You can't
prostitute our girls." That is the
reality of what's happening here. So,
the British public need to wake up. We
as Muslims need to realize there are
genuine concerns the British public have
and we need to be vocal about that and
tell them we are not their enemies. We
don't want the young British men and
women being degenerates. Alcohol
addiction, sex addiction, gambling
addiction, all these things that are
destroying them. Okay? Porn addiction.
Islam is the only force out there
against degeneracy. So we are your
allies if anything. And like we have
evidence from the Quran as well and and
and and from Islam that the Muslims were
rejoicing when the Romans defeated the
Persians because you guys are closer to
us than they are. So all I'm going to
say is this. I will most likely be
there. I'm still not sure. But if I am
there, I would love to talk to you guys
and I share ideas like civilized people
cuz we don't want hate. We want to live
in peace. This country is our my country
as well. Okay? I pay my taxes. I have a
family. If I saw a white British girl
being abused by anyone with any color,
I'll be the first to put my neck on the
line and my life on the line to protect
her. I don't care about a color. I don't
like, oh, it's a white girl. It's fine.
No, whoever it is. And we really need to
be vocal about that. And I hope, as you
can see, the march, I don't believe the
turnout is going to be the same. People
are waking up and seeing that this man,
Tommy Robinson, dude, does not care
about nationalism or the the girls. All
he cares about is who the perpetrators
are. And you can see this scumbag doing
that. And Allah is exposing him more.
And yes, that's all I have to say in my
brother sisters. And they are the
infight has already started and people
are waking up to his bull crap. And
what's what's the objective? Come away
for us. Come on guys. If you want to
make real changes, we need to work
together. You need to work with us
Muslims as well. Okay? We are not your
enemies. That's all I have to say.